CBS News has learned that United States
officials are increasingly concerned
about possible terrorist attacks on
airliners this means the ban on large
electronics on flights to the United
States from eight countries in the
Middle East and North Africa could be
extended that Piquet's is in Washington
Jeff good morning good morning for some
time US officials have been concerned
about trained Isis fighters making their
way from Syria and Iraq to European
countries where air travel to the u.s.
is easier and that is part of the
intelligence that US authorities believe
indicates that the threat picture for
commercial aviation is changing a US
official now tell CBS News that it is
evolving rapidly and sources say more
terrorists are gaining the knowledge
necessary to build a laptop bomb in
March CBS News confirmed that terrorist
groups have been testing a bomb that can
be hidden in a laptop computer in order
to evade security scanners some of the
intelligence was gathered at Mosul
University in Iraq where Isis was
testing how to get an explosive through
baggage screening equipment earlier this
year the Trump administration banned
larger electronics in the cabins of
airplanes traveling to the u.s. from
some airports in Africa and the Middle
East DHS Secretary John Kelly is still
weighing whether to expand that ban to
include Europe it would potentially
affect electronic devices larger than a
smartphone already sources say the
possibility of a band has prompted some
international airports to voluntarily
step up their security measures Gayle
thank you very much Jeff